we take a look now at wrapping up loose
financial ends as 2021 draws to a close
and one important area is charitable
giving
looking back 2020 was a record year in
the u.s individuals donated at least 471
billion dollars that is up by more than
20 billion from the year before
according to giving usa
and the good news of course is a special
tax break for charitable donations is
still in effect but it is set to expire
in a few weeks so you may want to give
to important causes now but you might
not be sure how to do it luckily we're
joined by our favorite personal finance
guru marsha mantel of mantel retirement
consulting marcia always amazing to
speak with you we've got just a few
weeks left of this year what's going to
be up with our charitable donations do
they still have a chance to make an
impact under these special tax
advantages and how do those work
they do and thanks for inviting me back
charitable giving we are such generous
people it turns out and the surprise in
2020 was you know we had a pandemic
so
i think the expectation was charitable
giving might have ratcheted quite a bit
back we had a lot of unemployment we had
a lot of angst we had moms at home
homeschooling you know it wasn't really
a focus to be charitably inclined
and yet it was so we are thrilled that
the charities that so need these
donations are still getting funding for
the most part in in the broad categories
and now we have an extension you're
exactly right maddie and scarlett that
the cares act
that brought back a
front of the 1040 deduction for some
charitable cash donations is still
available for the 2021 tax year so if
you file as a single person you can
contribute up to 300
that you can then deduct from your taxes
your tax obligation and if you are
married filing jointly you get up to six
hundred dollars so there's still time
there's a couple of weeks left and you
can still get considered a bit of a
bonus a little tax incentive i'm curious
how much that tax incentive plays into
people's
uh wanting to give i mean is that a big
driver because when there is no tax
incentive what does giving look like
you know it's such a good question and i
was so surprised as i was researching
and thinking that was exactly the case
that you know a few years ago when we
had the new tax reform come into play
the standard deductions got
significantly higher in fact they
doubled
and we were thinking and we were
concerned that people were going to stop
charity giving donating to the charities
because there wasn't a related tax
deduction you could only get that when
you itemized now pretty much only 10 of
people need to itemize
and that just didn't play out it just
shows that and in the surveys for people
who are giving we don't
give because of a tax break we give
because these are charities and causes
we love and want to support and know
they need our help
then if there's some bonus you get a
little bit additional tax break that's a
good thing too but the primary driver is
wanting to support these charities well
marcia i want to pick up on that because
i was fascinated that people who are
lower income are among the biggest
contributors to charitable causes what
do you make of that
yeah i think that is just amazing
maddie um what we see
year after year is
lower income households those 50 000 and
lower
they're giving a higher percentage of
their income
than people in making the hundred
thousand to five hundred thousand dollar
range i mean it speaks to how important
charitable giving is
regardless of your income now a lot of
it goes to religious organizations so we
have a lot of people very passionate
about their religion and supporting the
causes of their church or house of
worship we have a lot of pet lovers you
know a lot goes to the pets a lot goes
to cancer researcher alzheimer's
something that is maybe has personally
affected you so there's a lot of real
passion about where our dollars go and
understanding that the dollars we give
to charity does make a difference and
how do people give uh marcia are they
giving on a monthly basis where it's a
recurring payment or are they doing it
in one lump sum either at the beginning
of the year or at the end of the year
when it perhaps is most
advantageous tax wise or it's just
something that comes up when you're
getting ready to get all your papers in
order
well it's any and all of the above now
the charities will often tell you they
really prefer the recurring you know
five dollars a month ten dollars a month
25 a month whatever you can afford to
give and you have that hit your credit
card
um it works well for your cash flow
management and it works well for the
charity because they now have reliable
amounts that become their sort of their
base that they know is coming in each
month so that's a great way to go but if
you're a procrastinator like so many of
us
here in the middle of december you know
just writing one big check or you know
making one credit card contribution that
works well too so sticking with that i
feel like over the course of the past
two years particularly with a lot of
racial justice causes raising up on
instagram and things like that venmo has
become a really important part of the
charitable giving process um how does
one even begin to sort of keep track of
payments like that and then turn that
into
something that i would involve in my
taxes like i just have no idea where i
would even begin on that process
yeah and i happen to know maddie that
you're a millennial and i'll tell you
the millennial generation has a general
comment they have really embraced this
online giving using venmo or google pay
or whatnot the important thing i think
they're two really big things one is
that you make sure you're giving to an
actual bonafide 501c3
charity
and the other is that it is your
responsibility as the taxpayer you have
to get the documentation
so whether you see something come
through on a statement or whether like
with a credit card you would see that
actual charitable donation on your
credit card statement
or you get it from the charity and you
might have to request it but it's up to
you to track that and make sure you know
if it's five dollars a month to
you know standish cat rescue
make sure you're getting a document that
says you really did make those
contributions
at the same time when people are looking
for organizations i mean you mentioned
everyone has their kind of pet causes
that they want to give to but if you're
looking to broaden your scope and and
affect and
invest in emotionally and financially
more causes how do you go about vetting
different organizations
it's super important that you do that
and there are two organizations that are
kind of the the north stars for the the
charitable giving world
one is charity navigator
and it is charitynavigator.org
they show they show all the details for
any 501c3 organization
so if you just hop online and you can
either google your charity and get to
charity navigator or the other way you
want to look up the the place that you
want to actually give some of your
hard-earned money so make sure it's a
legitimate charity the navigator does a
very good job on a tremendous number
we're talking about somewhere around 1.4
1.5 million charities just in the us
and if you go overseas we've got another
eight or nine million so you do need to
vet the charities and make sure that
it's a legitimate place
and you can get that documentation
the other really good site is
givewell
givewell.org now give well does a really
deep dive into analyses on the charities
not just is it a legitimate charity but
what's its impact and so i talked about
this as a strategy if you really want to
maximize your impact
take a look at the nine or ten charities
that they have vetted to say of all the
ones out there these are the ones by the
numbers that spend the least amount of
money on administrative stuff you know
not on the people
and they maximize the impact that it
actually gives to people and communities
so one that they have it's very highly
rated as one of the malaria you know how
the netting in many of the countries in
africa if we can just put netting around
children's beds it prevents the
mosquitoes in and prevents malaria
or reduces it greatly
that's a huge impact for pennies
that's the kind of thing they're looking
for and it's just so interesting to see
the charities that they're ranking very
high for those reasons maximum impact
marcia really quickly here how do you
decide how much to give based on your
income
not how much it hurts you know you may
have heard that give till it hurts don't
give till it hurts
give an amount that you feel comfortable
with you can always change it next year
or if you can do only one time 25 this
year fantastic they'll appreciate it
because you basically end up pooling
all the money with everyone else who's
giving to that same charity so give what
you can and what you're comfortable with
a great reminder this holiday season of
the importance of giving marcia thank
you so much for being here that was
marcia mantel from mental retirement
consulting joining us in boston